The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
MICHAEL SHORT: Today I want
to pick up where we left off--
well, to remind you where
we left off last time,
we were watching videos
of crushing things
with the explicit purpose
of understanding material
properties, so that we can talk
a little bit about radiation
damage and nuclear materials.
Since I got more than
a few requests to say,
what's all this
nuclear materials?
It's like the biggest research
field in the department,
and yet, it's not
talked about in 22.01.
Well, now it is.
So we talked before about
all the different stages
in radiation damage from
creation of single defects
to their clustering into
things like voids or loops
and super structures
that have end up
having macroscopic effects
on material properties,
and all of them is due to
the production of crystal
and defects due to radiation.
And to refresh your
memory quickly,
I'm going to jump ahead
to the stress strain curve
that we were looking at before
we started watching videos
of crushing things,
to remind you
about the different
material properties
and what they actually mean.
So anyone remember what we
mean by toughness in relation
to this curve?
AUDIENCE: The area [INAUDIBLE]
MICHAEL SHORT: That's right.
The amount of energy it
would take to actually cause
this material to fail.
That's a measure of toughness.
How about strength?
Remember this curve is stress,
which is a force per unit area,
versus strain, which is
an amount of elongation.
The strength of the
material is how much
stress you can put
in until it starts
to either plastically
deform or it
hits its UTS, ultimate tensile
strength, where it will just
fail.
How about ductility?
What do we mean by that?
Either intuitively or
on the curve, yeah?
AUDIENCE: How much
you can stretch it?
MICHAEL SHORT: Exactly.
How much you can stretch
it before it fails,
indicated by this
point right here.
The strain to failure would
be a good measure of activity.
And finally, stiffness.
What do you think?
Stiffness is more of
a response function,
so it's how much does it deform
in relation to how much stress
you put into it.
So it's the slope
of this part right
here, so that's why I
want you guys to know
that we mean actually
different physical things
by these properties, which
will be important to note
when we start to discuss what
radiation damage actually does.
So the basic mechanism
of radiation damage
is like you might imagine.
Let's say this green particle
is a neutron or a heavy ion
or a proton or an
electron or anything.
Anything that's energetic enough
to cause atomic displacement.
So as that neutron
or whatever enters,
it will strike some of the
atoms in this perfect crystal,
creating what's called a
primary knock on atom, or PKA,
for short.
And then that neutron
and the released PKA
will go on to hit
more and more atoms,
resulting in what we
call a damage cascade,
leaving behind a lot of
different types of defects.
We talked about these
last time, but I'll just
refresh your memory.
A vacancy is a type of defect
that, well, it's not really
a thing, right?
It's just the absence of
where an atom would have been,
but we refer to them
as defects of their own
that can diffuse and
move because let's say
another atom moved into the
position of this vacancy.
Then we can say the vacancy
moved to that atomic position.
There's also
interstitials, or atoms
where they shouldn't quite be.
And this leaves behind
a whole bunch of damage
that we quantify using
a measure called DPA,
or displacements per atom.
It's a simple measure of how
many times has every atom left.
It's a lot of sight.
That's it, though.
It's not actually
a unit of damage,
and I'll be giving
a talk at MRS,
the materials research
conference tomorrow, railing
against this DPA
unit because I'm
going to explain this
a little bit right now.
What is a DPA?
A DPA measures the
number of times
that each atom has moved
out of its original site,
but it has nothing to do with
how many times it stays out
of its original site
because a lot of those atoms
will get knocked away and
then just move right back,
but the DPA part
only measure is what
we call the ballistic
stage of radiation damage.
Let's see if this works.
I've just realized I
can jump back to a slide
without inducing epilepsy.
Yeah.
So what DPA actually measures
is how many times does
this process happen?
How many times do the
atoms get knocked around?
But it says nothing
about where they end up,
and that's the really
interesting part
about specifically
radiation material science.
Because let's say one
of these interstitials
were then to combine with
one of these vacancies.
It's like they were never there.
Even though they were
displaced, and would
be counted as part of the DPA,
or the radiation damage dose,
the net effect on the
crystal material is nothing.
So let's say what
really the DPA is.
It's a simple formula that I
think you guys may recognize.
This look familiar
from all of neutronics
that we've been doing?
It's yet another reaction rate.
It's an energy dependent
flux times another type
of cross-section that we
call the damage displacement
cross-section, or
sigma D, and it's
integrated over your
entire energy range,
and that's all there is to it.
So with what you know 22.01, you
can understand the basic unit
of radiation damage.
As you might imagine, we've had
four lectures on neutronics,
so if you can
understand all there
is to know about DPA after
four sophomore lectures,
it's probably a
pretty simple unit.
You're right, it is.
What goes into this damaged
displacement cross-section
is also something that
might look a little familiar
is a cross section
that says, what's
the probability of some
particle coming in with energy E
and imparting kinetic energy
T to another struck atom?
That comes right from--
remember our treatment--
I think I've drawn this
probably 50 times now.
Our hollow cylinder treatment
of a charged particle
with charge little ze
interacting with a particle
a big ZE at some
impact parameter B.
We wanted to know well,
for all possible approach
paths, the area of
this hollow circle,
or the probability that
this particular approach
path is taken, is just
the area here 2pi b db.
With some constants
in front of it,
which actually is
that cross section
what's the probability that our
particle goes in with energy E
and imparts kinetic energy T?
It's directly related to
that impact parameter B.
And this is the same thing
that you're seeing right here.
You then multiply by
this little function
nu of T, which represents
the amount of damage,
or the number of
displacements done,
for each one of these reactions.
And there are simple models,
there are mostly linear models
for--
if a particle comes in with
energy E, leaves with energy T,
how many displacements happen?
It's a pretty simple
linear piece-wise model,
and that fairly
well approximates
the number of
displacements that happen,
but I want to get the
idea of DPA versus damage.
They're two very
different things,
and they're often equated.
Much like the material
properties of strength,
ductility, hardness,
and toughness
are equated in
colloquial speech,
but that's absolutely wrong.
So is the idea of DPA
and radiation damage.
Because DPA, again,
just measures
the number of times that
an atom is displaced.
Damage is some measure of
the number of messed up atoms
at the end of the
game, and they operate
in very different timescales.
It takes femtoseconds
to picoseconds
for a damage cascade to happen.
So the DPA is all over in
less than a picosecond,
but it can take years for
all these different defects
to diffuse, to cluster up, and
to form these super structures,
and actually end up
causing the damage that
can lead to material
property degradation.
So what sort of
factors would affect
the speed at which these
different defects end up
finding each other?
What could you vary about a
material or its environment
to change the speed of these
atomic diffusion jumps?
AUDIENCE: Temperature.
MICHAEL SHORT: Indeed.
Temperature.
Reading off my list-- well,
the whole list jumped up.
OK.
You got the first one.
What were you going to say?
AUDIENCE: I was going
to say temperature also.
MICHAEL SHORT: OK.
Yeah, absolutely.
Temperature determines
diffusivities.
It also can change phases
or crystal arrangements,
like for the case of
anything iron-based.
The dose rate, the rate at
which those neutrons come in
can change the rate at which
the defects cluster up.
Chemistry, if you have solute
atoms, which I've drawn here.
You may have let's say
chromium atoms and iron,
and the chromium atoms
are a little bit bigger.
Defects may be
attracted to or repelled
to those extra solute atoms,
changing the way that they
interact with each other.
And then micro structure.
Things that are bigger
than on the order of atoms.
Grain boundaries, dislocations,
all of those defects
that we talked about last
time, just to refresh
your memory of what those are.
We have been talking about
zero dimensional defects
like vacancies.
We spent a while on
dislocations, these one
dimensional defects that other
defects can be attracted to.
We saw an example of a
two dimensional defect,
known as a grain
boundary, where you
can see this line between
different arrangements
of atoms.
And there can be three
dimensional defects.
Like inclusions of some separate
face sitting in the material.
Like the manganese sulfide we
found in the Alcator fusion
reactors power rotor.
And all of the
presence and density
of all those
different defects can
be quite strongly influenced.
Let me start that sentence over.
The movement in clustering
of those defects
can be quite strongly
influenced by the presence
of all those other defects.
So again, the DPA
actually tells us
this part of radiation
damage, and that's
what we tend to simulate
with these ballistic binary
collision approximation
simulations,
where we just say
like billiard balls,
how many atoms knock
into each other?
What it doesn't tell
us is everything else,
and it's the stuff that
happens here that can tell us
will our materials fail
in nuclear reactors?
And there's evidence for this.
I'm not just ranting
against it, no I am,
but I'm doing so with
evidence, so it's justified.
So here's a nice
experiment I like to show
in every talk for this case.
These folks took pure nickel
and put it in the same reactor,
at the same temperature, and
got the same amount of swelling.
All the conditions
were the same.
Same temperature, same
materials, same microstructure,
same reactor, same
neutron energies.
Just a different dose rate.
A 30% difference in
the rate at which
neutrons arrived at
the nickel, and they
get the same result
in void swelling, one
of those bad things
that happens,
at two and a half times
the DPA, which tells us
that there's a very
strong dose rate effect
for material damage.
So if you want to answer
the question, well,
how much dose does it take to
reach 3% swelling in nickel?
Can't answer that question, you
don't have enough information.
Even if you say, how
much dose does it
take with one of the neutrons
at 600 Celsius in this one
reactor?
You can't answer that question.
Kind of tricky.
And a lot of the rest of
nuclear materials data
looks something like this.
Now, I don't want you to
worry about what the axes say.
They're not readable because
they're not important.
What I do want you to know is
what's the quality of this data
set you see?
Would you be bold enough
to draw a trend line
through a single data point?
No.
What about three where
it doesn't actually
match up with one of them?
Or is there any
reason why you think
they made this parabolic
instead of a linear line?
I can draw a line that
would fit between the error
bars of these two right here.
So the trick is doing these
experiments is extremely
difficult and expensive.
So just throwing something near
the MIT reactor for a month,
because we did this, we took
a few hundred milligrams
of copper, aluminum,
and nickel, threw it
in near core position of the MIT
reactor, and that cost $40,000,
and that did about 0.002
DPA, or about the dose
that you'd receive in a normal
power reactor in one day.
If you want to actually
say how long will it
take to get materials to the
end of their useful life,
this tends to be anywhere from
10 DPA in light water reactors,
to hundreds of DPA in
proposed fast reactors
to 500 DPA for TerraPower's
traveling wave reactor.
Now, I don't particularly have--
let's see what's 500
divided by 0.00--
I don't have 10,000 years to
wait for the final answer.
The best we can do right
now is to stick them
in a reactor called
BOR-60 in Russia.
I've actually been there.
It's in the very Western
edge of Siberia--
I don't know if you
could call it that--
in a city called Dimitrovgrad.
They have a sodium
cooled fast reactor.
For those of you
who are wondering
when our advanced reactor
is going to be built,
they are built. Just not in
this country, not very much.
But Russia's got
a fleet of sodium
cooled fast reactors that
can get you 25 DPA per year.
And if your reactor is
going to go to 500 DPA,
you have to know whether or not
your materials will survive,
you have to wait 20
years for the answer.
So what investor is going
to be like, all right,
here's $10 billion,
but I can wait 20 years
for a return on investment.
No.
I can wait 20 years
to start building
the reactor, which
means 40 years
for a return on investment.
Chances are, if someone's
got $10 billion to give,
they're going to be dead by
the time they get a return.
So this is a no win proposition.
So what we really
need to know is
what is the full population
of every single type of defect
in an irradiated material?
That's what I mean by damage.
Did I show you guys
this movie yet?
The orange one?
We've talked about vacancies
in an abstract sense,
but this is a movie of
one of them actually
moving about on the
surface of germanium.
So this is a scanning
tunneling microscope image--
I think that's what
it stands for--
and these are atoms on
the surface of germanium.
And that right there,
that darker orange thing
moving about is
vacancy diffusion.
It's actually happening.
You can see it in real time.
AUDIENCE: Is this
real time then?
MICHAEL SHORT:
Pretty much, yeah.
So I think this was-- yeah--
30 frames a second, or so.
Anyway, I don't
remember exactly,
but I'd say that's why I
always reference everything
in the presentations.
I encourage you
guys to look it up.
And then the only reason
these slides aren't up yet
is because they're
300 megabytes,
and I didn't have the bandwidth
to upload that from my house.
Now that I'm on campus, I can
get a 300 meg presentation
up there because
it's full of movies.
What sort of things could
happen to these defects?
So radiation produces
all these crazy defects,
then the DPA
description is over.
What could happen next?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MICHAEL SHORT: Sorry,
Jared, and then-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: Material could crack.
MICHAEL SHORT:
Material could crack.
That would be the
worst case scenario,
but that is indeed what
happens in the end,
and I'll show you some pictures
of that actually happened.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
that displaced atoms
can find their way back?
MICHAEL SHORT: Yep.
So they could recombine with
different types of defects
and annihilate each other.
If you have a vacancy and
an interstitial nearby,
the interstitial
can plug the hole
of the vacancy and your left
with another perfect crystal.
But now what happens if two
vacancies find each other?
Then you've got the
makings of a void,
or we then call
it a small vacancy
cluster of two vacancies,
but it's actually
more stable for these
vacancies or interstitials
to find each other
and make these larger
defects than it is
for them to sit alone
in the crystal structure.
So there is a thermodynamic
driving force bringing them
together, and then as
those defects build up,
then what Jared
said could happen.
You could crack the material
because it could get weaker,
less ductile, less tough.
Weaker is the
opposite of strong,
and what's the other one?
Toughness-- oh, and
harder, actually.
So the origins
avoid swelling I'll
start with the humble vacancy.
A void is nothing but
a bunch of vacancies
or a pocket of vacuum
or gas in a material,
and it all has to start
with these single vacancies.
As they cluster together,
they reached this threshold
in terms of free energy
where putting a few of them
together is not quite
energetically favorable,
but it's not so unfavorable
that it never happens.
So once in a while, you'll get a
few vacancies to come together,
and that cluster will
survive for a little while.
All the while, you're making
more and more vacancies nearby,
and if it gets to
a certain size,
that free energy goes negative.
And when the free
energy goes negative,
it becomes stable on its
own, and then that void
will simply continue to
grow, and grow, and grow.
And so there's this process
of absorption and emission
of defects by larger
or smaller void,
so if you have a whole bunch
of voids near each other,
some of them can be
emitting vacancies,
which can be captured
by the other ones,
and this is part of why they
don't all just disappear
at once.
They have finite
lifetimes, long enough
that you can build
them up to the size
where they become stable.
Then this free energy eventually
curves down, becomes negative,
and then they just stick
around, and we've actually
seen these clusters
or voids diffusing,
so it's not like vacancies alone
are the only thing that moves.
We've actually seen clusters
of defects diffusing, mostly
in one dimension, but
what you're seeing here
is a TEM, or transmission
electron microscope image,
of one dimensional diffusion
of a vacancy cluster.
That little black
blob right there
is a pocket of vacuum that's
moving back and forth.
And if it happens to find
another pocket of vacuum,
it could then combine
to a bigger pocket,
becoming a bigger
and bigger void.
The other problem too
is that most materials
generate helium when you
irradiate them with neutrons.
Did we go over the what's called
the N alpha cross-section?
Does that sound
familiar to anyone?
All right, I'm going
to pull up Janice
like I do pretty
much every class.
Let me show you what's going on.
But this is an
important one to note.
Because a pocket a vacuum
is not that stable,
but if you get a
little bit of gas
to stabilize that
pocket of vacuum,
then that pressure
differential goes down
and that void becomes a bubble,
and that bubble is more stable.
Good.
Because on the
last isotope, where
I was showing someone
[INAUDIBLE] alpha
cross-section.
How convenient.
So among the millions
of cross sections
that we've gone through,
there is this one right
here called Z alpha.
So what-- Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHAEL SHORT: Got
to clone the screen.
That's right.
Thanks.
There we go.
So there's this one here
called Z alpha, which
means neutron comes in,
alpha particle goes out,
alpha particle is
just an ionized helium
ion, which very quickly
pulls in two electrons
from anywhere else in the
metal and becomes helium gas.
And this cross-section
is not zero,
especially at higher energy
starting around 2 MeV,
there is a small, but
non-negligible chance
that a neutron will go in,
and a helium atom comes out.
And those helium
atoms have nowhere
to go, they find the
easiest place to sit,
that happens to be
pockets of vacuum.
Voids.
And what that actually does
is stabilizes those voids so
the curve I showed
you back here.
This is the case of free energy
for a vacuum pocket of void,
and that free energy gets
lower and lower as you start
to fill that void with gas.
So as the voids
fill with gas, they
become more and more stable,
and a lot of materials
generate their own gas.
So that's that, and they end
up forming these bubbles.
You guys remember, last time
I showed you a bunch of voids.
They look like diamonds all
aligned in the same direction.
What do you see different here?
They're not quite
circles, right?
But they're kind of
round edge squares.
They are also all pointing
in the same direction.
If you look carefully
at this one,
this one, the one above it.
And the big one over there.
It's harder to see
for the small ones,
but for these
three big ones, you
can see that they're all
rotated in the same direction,
giving away the crystal
orientation of the material.
But the reason that
they're starting
to swell up from diamonds into
bubbles, is they're full of gas
and they stabilize the voids.
You can also get
dislocation buildup.
Normally, you would have
to deform a material
to create and move dislocations,
but when you apply radiation,
you can just create
dislocations.
I mean look at that.
This is kind of cool.
You've got a dislocation
source right here.
Every one of those lines
you see is a dislocation,
and you can see it's spiraling
out and ejecting dislocations
from this one little spot.
Any combination
of small clusters
can collapse into dislocations
or the stress induced
from irradiating things
can cause more stress that
can move more dislocations.
You create what's
called this network
forest of dislocations
that makes
things a lot harder to deform.
So let's see, I want to show
a couple more videos of this
because it's very
clear in some of these.
You can actually see along
these lines right here
a few different orientations
of dislocations,
and if you watch
up here, you can
see some dislocations
moving, and then
there's a source that
emits more right there,
and so all the time, you're
creating dislocations
that are being emitted
from different places
and colliding with each other.
The trick that we
didn't talk about yet,
is when dislocations
from different directions
collide, they get stuck.
And when they get
stuck, they can't move.
And when they can't move, you
shift the balance from slip
to fracture, which
means, like Jared said,
it's easier to just break
something, rather than
plastically deform it.
And the effects of this
are things like stiffening.
An increase in the
Young's Modulus.
Because if you remove
some of the compliance
from the material or make
it stiffer by injecting
all sorts of
different defects, it
takes more stress to
impart the same strain.
That might not be a
bad thing on its own.
Your materials get stronger,
that sounds like a good thing,
right?
Not always because it doesn't
just come as stiffening.
But now from an
atomic point of view,
why does this stiffening happen?
Anybody have an idea?
I'm going to jump back to
the stress strain curve.
So the stress, or the
yield stress of a material,
is usually defined as
this point right here.
When you go from elastic
reversible deformation
to irreversible
plastic deformation.
If something gets
stronger, it means
that this yield stress goes up.
And if something gets stiffer,
it means the slope goes up.
These two tend to
happen at the same time.
So if something is
stiffer and stronger, then
the stress strain curve would
be drawn more like that.
And what actually physically
happens at this point?
This is when dislocations
start to move.
Dislocation movement
is irreversible.
You can't just snap it back
when you relieve the stress.
And by making something
stronger and stiffer,
you make it more difficult
for those dislocations
to start moving.
And you can do that by throwing
any defect in their way.
And since radiation creates
pretty much any and all
defects, it's a great way
to stiffen and strengthen
the material.
So one of the reasons things
get stiffer and stronger
is, remember before we showed
you that video of dislocation
sliding through material?
Folks don't remember.
I'll bring it up right now.
I didn't see a lot
of shaking heads.
This one, right?
This one right here.
So remember, before,
we showed you
the way that dislocations move.
So the ways that materials
can deform without breaking.
If you throw
anything in its way,
you're going to make this
process a lot more difficult.
And all radiation damage does
is throw things in the way.
So if you throw
absolutely anything
in the way from solute atoms
to interstitials to vacancies,
all of a sudden, it's
harder for that dislocation
to move because some of those
bonds are stretched out,
or there's a few extra
atoms in the way.
And you can then
start to create what's
called little pin
sections called jogs.
Let's say a little vacancy
moves over to this dislocation,
meaning that it goes up
by one atomic position.
Then you've got pieces
of this dislocation that
are not in this preferential
slip plane, and they get stuck.
So all of a sudden you go
from a completely gliding--
or what we call
glissile dislocation--
to one that's stuck,
or sessine, those
are the actual material
science words that we use.
And what it ends up leading to
is a strong loss in ductility.
At the same time as things
get stronger and stiffer,
they tend to get
much less ductile.
So what you're looking
at here are fuel shrouds.
These are fuel boxes that
surround the fuel pins
in a Russian sodium fast
reactor, and usually
what you do is you would
grab onto this piece right
here and lift up to remove
this fuel from the reactor
during refueling.
What happened here is they grab
that, they started to pull,
and they heard a little clink,
and up came half the fuel box,
and the fuel stayed down
in the reactor with no way
to pull it out.
So this is the reason why
radiation damage is such
an important field of
study is you might not
know anything has happened
until you shut the reactor down
and go to take out
the fuel and realize
that you can't
because everything
is as brittle as glass.
This is actually a
talk I saw yesterday.
We had a summer visitor in
our lab from Kazakhstan.
And most of their
radioactive materials
came from this
reactor that shut down
in 1999 on one
side of Kazakhstan,
and they wanted to
transport those materials
to the other side.
So they hired the
cheapest truck drivers
to go on the bumpy roads.
And the scientists were
freaking out, because only
they knew that all of the metal
that all those guys thought
was going to be
ductile like metal
was more brittle than glass.
And any sort of bump would
cause just complete shattering
of this metal and
catastrophic release
of radioactive material.
So this took them--
let's see-- I think Kazakhstan
is smaller than the US.
So who here has done
a cross-country trip?
How long it take you?
AUDIENCE: Six days
from Seattle to here.
MICHAEL SHORT: OK, and did
you stop along the way?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MICHAEL SHORT: OK, so this
trip took them 13 days
because they went slow.
And I don't think the
roads in Kazakhstan
are as good as they are in most
of the middle of the country.
The coasts are terrible, but
the middle is pretty good.
So this trip went slow
because the scientists
said this happens.
You should be careful.
And luckily, there were
no problems and no release
of radioactive material.
Pretty cool.
What you want to happen
is for dislocations
to move on the easiest planes.
And so what I have
redrawn here is,
let's say you've got
a bar of some metal,
some face-centered cubic metal,
as you pull on it, like this,
it will actually deform at
about a 45 degree angles.
You might wonder,
why does that happen?
But if you look
carefully here, what's
the closest packed plane
of atoms that you can see?
It's not this plane normal
to the stress direction.
It's like this one
or like this one,
and so you actually end
up getting deformation
in what's called slip plains,
or the easiest directions
for things to deform.
And without going into any
of the math or atomistics,
I just want to show you
some examples pulled out
of, again, the fusion reactor.
So this is a piece of rotor
steel from the same Alcator
rotor where we found
that inclusion.
We were pulling it in
this direction, and look
what formed.
All of these slip bands
at 45 degree angles,
showing you that
just because you
pull in something
in one direction,
doesn't mean it deforms
in that direction.
It deforms and little
slices in the direction
that dislocations
can move the easiest.
So when you actually
pull on something,
to show you diagrammatically,
it deforms something like that.
You get a mixture of
bending and rotation
to make it look like the bar
is bending uniformly straight,
but on the microscale, it's not.
So this is a pretty slick image
of a single crystal of cadmium
being pulled in this
direction, and you can actually
see every plane there,
that's a slip plane.
That's a plane
where dislocations
have been moving all the way
to the outside of the material,
which is pretty cool,
and this is the process
that you want to happen.
Anything in the way
of those dislocations,
you don't start forming
these slip bands,
and you'd make it more
preferable that the thing will
just break and fracture.
To show you some extreme
examples of slip,
that's when you have to go nano.
So these are some
pillar compression test
that used a focused
ion beam, which
we will be using to top
off our study of electron
interactions with matter
and ion interactions
to take a piece of metal and
carve out a little cylinder.
And all they did is smash.
They came down and compressively
pushed on the cylinder,
and look how it deformed.
Not in the way you might
intuitively expect,
if you don't know
any material science.
So it deformed all
on 45 degree angles
and very weird compression.
Not actually weird, if
you know what's going on.
there's lots more
neat examples of this.
If you don't push too
hard, you can actually
see these perfectly symmetrical
slip planes at 45 degree angles
to the axis of
compression, and you
know every one of these
pillars you see this happening.
And this is what you want to
happen to nuclear materials
because you're really
trying to balance
this between slip and fracture
towards the direction of slip.
That means that something will
deform a little bit before it
just shatters like those channel
boxes from the Russian reactor.
Any questions on
what I said before I
go on to the
macroscale properties?
All right, and let's get
into the real world stuff.
What actually causes
this embrittlement?
Well, there's a few things.
Remember we saw videos of those
dislocations in a traffic jam.
If not, then I'll refresh
your guy's memory.
It's a phenomenon called
pileup, let's see.
There is the traffic jam.
Do you guys remember
this video now--
I know it's been a week,
but these dislocations
are moving and feeling
each other's stress,
and so they can't move as
easily as they would want to,
so you end up with a
phenomenon called pileup.
This happens both near
other dislocations
and near any other defect
that gets in the way,
like a grain boundary.
So for smaller materials you
end up with more of this pileup,
and they tend to be of a fair
bit stronger, and a fair bit--
they can be less ductile,
with some exceptions.
I won't say they're
always less ductile,
but if you put anything
in the way, notice,
this just says barrier.
Any other defect can
act as a barrier.
And this ends up
shifting what we
call the ductile-brittle
transition temperature.
This is the property
that people worry
about for reactor
pressure vessels,
because you would want the
pressure vessel, which in cases
the entire core of
the reactor, to always
be ductile in the worst
possible situation.
The worst possible situation
is on the absolute last day
of operation at the
coldest temperature
it could possibly be.
As you guys know, or
you probably know,
when you make something colder,
it tends to be more brittle.
So who's frozen stuff in liquid
nitrogen and broken it before?
Good.
I'm glad to see a
few hands, so what
do you guys freeze and break?
So just like froze a bottle of
Pepto Bismol and shattered it?
Nice.
That must have been a
fun mess to clean up.
Yeah, what about you, Sarah?
AUDIENCE: A banana and a coin.
MICHAEL SHORT: Cool, OK.
And we're able to
break the coin?
There you go.
So normally you'd be
able to bend a coin,
or if it's a one yen coin,
you can bite through it.
Not when immersed in liquid
nitrogen. What about you,
Charlie?
AUDIENCE: Flowers.
MICHAEL SHORT: Flowers, OK.
Classic.
So take a rose and shatter it.
Yeah.
All these normally ductile
materials become extremely
brittle when they get colder.
So do reactor pressure vessels.
The problem is, they
don't just get brittle
when they get to liquid
nitrogen temperatures.
At the end of their
life, they can
be brittle at room temperature
from radiation damage.
So there is what's called a
ductile-brittle transition
temperature before a pressure
vessels are irradiated,
there's about this 50% line,
whatever this temperature was
where you have let's say,
50%, or 10%, or 0% ductility.
Whatever measure
you're using, you
say, OK, we always
want to make sure
that it's got a certain
amount of energy absorption
capability, toughness,
at a certain temperature.
And as you irradiate
that vessel,
this shifts over this way, and
this upper amount of energy,
this USE, or what we
call upper shelf energy,
because this looks like
a shelf, goes down.
What you want to make
sure is that this change
in ductile-brittle
transition temperature
never reaches room temperature.
You might think, oh, it's OK,
reactors run at 300 Celsius,
and things are pretty
ductile right there.
Well, you usually have to shut
the reactor down once you're
done with it to refuel, and
if something goes wrong,
there's a pressure
spike, you can
have a condition called
pressurized thermal shock,
or PTS.
In that case, you would have
a sudden pressure wave from,
let's say, from steam explosion
or whatever you could have,
and you want that vessel to
be able to absorb that energy
instead of breaking in half,
because if you break it half,
that's a radioactive release.
The way you test ductile-brittle
transition temperature
is what's called a
Charpy impact test.
It's probably the highest tech,
lowest tech test I've seen.
You simply hit
things with a hammer.
A very well calibrated,
precise hammer.
Let me pause so you can see
what the sample looks like.
You have these little
bars with a notch in them.
The notch is to make sure that
acts as a stress concentrator,
and you know where the
breaks going to happen.
So in a Charpy test, you
line up this little sample,
and you've got-- actually
in your reactors, usually,
you've got pieces of
the pressure vessel
in this form lining the inside
rim of the reactor pressure
vessel.
So every time you
refuel your reactor,
you take off another
few of these out
and you hit them with a
very well calibrated hammer.
And you can measure by
actually turning this dial
and letting the hammer
turn it as it moves
through the
material, you can see
how much energy was
absorbed by the material
as the hammer comes back up.
So it breaks right through
the material, in this case,
it's in a quenched or brittle
condition, and for some reason,
they have a lot of footage
of the guy standing
and not breathing,
but what I want
to show you is what
actually happens here.
I didn't make the
video, I just got it.
There we go.
So what you can see is
that if the hammer were
to move through air
with absolutely no drag,
it would come back
to the zero position.
If they had encountered
some resistance,
like with a piece
of steel in the way,
it then measures the
amount of energy in joules
that piece of steel absorbs
from the hammer blow.
The larger that is, the better.
And by doing this
test at a number
of different
temperatures, you can
recreate this ductile-brittle
transition temperature curve.
So they'll take a
few Charpy coupons,
they will test them at,
let's say, every 25 Celsius,
get a bunch of points, draw
the line through the points,
and decide where is
the material brittle.
At what temperature
will it become brittle?
To show you what something looks
like when it's not brittle.
The same test is
done in what's called
the normalized condition,
where you simply heat
the steel to a high
temperature, relaxing out
most of the defects, and
bringing back as much
of the perfect crystal
structure as possible, which
is really good for letting
dislocations move through it.
So the same test is done by
the same awkward feller who
likes to stand there
and not breathe,
but you'll notice a very
different result of this test.
Doesn't look like it,
but if you actually
look at how much energy was
absorbed, much, much higher.
So something like 18
times more energy,
and you can qualitatively
see the difference
between these two
conditions by looking
at the fractured surfaces,
and this is where
it starts to get intuitive.
Something that's
ductile would tear more
like taffy, where
something that's brittle
would cleave or break
in half much more
smoothly, so these are
the two pieces of metal
that we just showed.
You the one that absorbed 180
joules by lots of defamation,
and the one that absorbed
10 joules by fracture
in a brutal way.
This is what you want your
reactor vessel to behave like,
but the problem with these
ductile-brittle transition
temperature curves, is
this not just this part
that you're worried
about, it's that part.
So even at high temperatures,
things get less ductile.
So it's a combination of
temperature and number
of defects.
And if either one of
these criteria fails,
if you become too brittle
at low temperature,
or your total ductility at high
temperature goes down too much,
that's the end of life
of your reactor vessel,
and this is one of the biggest
problems in life extensions
of light water reactors.
They were built for 40
years and they originally
had license for 40 years.
How many of you guys have heard
of the license extensions going
on now, to 60 or 80 years?
Yeah, so a few of you guys.
I've heard heard, why not
run the reactor longer.
Not build a new one,
but keep getting
all this clean green
cheap nuclear energy?
This is why.
You have to be absolutely
sure that your vessel,
your primary containment,
will survive.
And we're not so
sure because well, we
jump to the part of the video
that's got the Charpy coupons.
Those.
We ran out.
We only plan to put
these vessels in service
for 40 years, and folks put 40
years worth of these coupons,
plus some extras, in
the reactor vessel.
Now, in order to prove
that it's actually
safe to continue
operation, you have
to have some amount
of material to test
and say, OK, this
vessel is still ductile,
it's still going to work.
What happened?
What do you do when
you run out of coupons?
Anyone have any
ideas, because I'm
sure the industry would
love to hear them.
AUDIENCE: Would you have
to start using material
from the vessel itself?
MICHAEL SHORT: You could start
using material from the vessel.
That's actually what I plan
to do too, but with some very
strong caveat.
So if you were to scoop
out a piece of the vessel,
you then create a
stress concentration.
In addition, reactor vessel
looks like a gigantic forging
of really thick carbon
steel with a very thin liner
of stainless steel.
And the stainless steel is
there to prevent corrosion
from the reactor water.
That thin, quarter inch
bit of stainless steel
is what actually
saved what could
have been one of the worst
nuclear accidents in US
history, the Davis
Bessie plant, where there
was a crack in the vessel.
Boric acid actually ate
through a whole chunk
of the pressure vessel, leaving
the stainless steel intact.
And it's that little quarter
inch stainless steel that
saved the plant.
But if you were to
take something out
from the inside of the vessel,
the part that gets the most
damage, you'd be taking out some
of the stainless steel, which
is a problem.
You could take a piece out
from here, maybe the outside,
but then you've got a
stress concentrator.
Any sort of chunk
that is missing
is where a crack is going
to preferentially form,
so you would weaken that
vessel by taking a piece out.
Anyone else have any ideas?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is it impossible
to just replace the vessel?
MICHAEL SHORT: Yes.
A new vessel means
a new reactor.
So the license for the
plant is intimately
tied to the license
for the vessel.
Any other ideas?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The creation of the
vessel, just put extra in there
and then take that out.
MICHAEL SHORT: That's
what they did, right?
So that's why these
Charpy coupons were there,
but what do we do about the
vessels that we already have?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can you make
Charpy coupon or coupons
that are similar to the status
of the ones most recently taken
out of the vessel, and
then just put them in?
MICHAEL SHORT: That's
what they're doing.
So they're taking these
Charpy coupons, which this
is bigger than actual size.
They break them, so let's say
this region's all garbage,
and then they cut a little
mini Charpy coupons out
of the last piece, and
they're putting those back in.
So that's absolutely right.
You've just probably recreated
a year's worth of licensing work
and ideas and in a class.
But I just want to get
back to Charlie's idea
because that's what
I think has to happen
is you'd like to be
able to take a piece out
from the actual vessel
and run a test on it.
The only way to do
that is to go nano.
Take the tiniest,
tiniest little piece out,
and perform some other
sort of measurement.
So this is the
idea that our group
has had in using what's called
stored energy of radiation
damage, so I don't mind
telling you about it,
even though it's not like
funded or papered yet
because it's educational,
and it's cool.
So every kind of defect
takes energy to create.
Defects don't just
create themselves.
You either have to raise the
temperature of a material
or in our case, irradiate it.
And it's the energy of
those incoming neutrons that
bounces around different
atoms and creates
all these different
types of defects.
So those defects are storing
energy in the material.
And so if you think about
how much energy does it
take to destroy
something, it would
have to be the energy that it's
already stored plus the energy
that you put into
it during the test
can reach the failure energy.
What if you could measure
the stored energy?
What if there was
a way to know how
many of each of those
defects there actually
were in a material?
We think there is.
Well, we know there is.
It's called differential
scanning color imagery.
It's a way of
measuring the change
in heat capacity of a
material, where you take two
very small furnaces--
you don't have to put this
in your notes, by the way,
this is just for fun.
You take two small furnaces,
put your chunk of your material
on one, and you apply a lot
of heat to both of them.
And you look at the difference
in the amount of heat
you have to put in to keep the
two at the same temperature.
So normally, you would
get the heat capacity
of a material, how much heat
can extort per degree Kelvin.
If this material's got a bunch
of defects already in it,
then you should release that
defect energy by heating it
and that would take a little
less energy to heat it up,
but there's a lot of
problems with calorimetry,
so we're actually using
what's called nanocalorimetry.
We're doing this process
on nanograms of material
and seeing if you can
irradiate something and measure
its stored energy
because if you could,
you could take a tiny
little razor blade,
take out the smallest
sliver of the vessel--
smaller than a grain of sand.
Not enough to cause a crack--
enough to measure
its stored energy.
And I want to show you guys
what this process looks like.
So I'm just going to deviate
from the actual lecture,
and jump into the topic
I'll give tomorrow.
I think it's more interesting
and more relevant.
There we go.
I'm going to skip through
some of this stuff,
but it's within the
last five minutes,
I'll try to get through this,
see if this is a record.
It's what we call the
ultimate snipe hunt.
Has anyone here been
on a snipe hunt?
What's a snipe hunt?
AUDIENCE: People bringing
you in the woods and tell you
you're looking for a
bird that doesn't exist.
MICHAEL SHORT: That's right.
Pretty much this, right?
They say bang a bunch
of sticks, get a bag,
and go look for snipes.
They don't exist, right?
They actually do.
Snipes are real.
You pretty much have to
be British to know it,
because they hunt
them there for sport,
and apparently,
they're delicious.
That's actually where
we get the term snipe
because the actual size of the
sniper compared to the sniper
is about that.
If you can shoot
that bird with a gun,
you are an expert marksman and
deserve the delicious and tiny
treat that you've then blown
apart with your bullet--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHAEL SHORT: Yeah, exactly.
So you can you know rain
bird dust on whatever meal
you've already prepared.
That's what I like in finding
these radiation damage
defects too.
Because some
experiments have been
done to plot the number of
defects versus their size.
And as the defects get bigger,
the number of them decrease.
So most defects are very, very
small, and it turns out that--
first of all, the resolution
of the screen is funny.
I think I know how to fix that.
Clone the screen and then
jump back to presenter mode.
That usually-- that's
not what I wanted.
That's what I wanted, great.
Most of the defects that cause
these reductions in material
properties are too small to
see, even in the transmission
electron microscope.
So I don't have to tell you this
stuff again, that I don't like
the DPA, I showed you that.
What we want is that.
We took some
inspiration directly
from the Manhattan Project.
Luckily, I have an uncle who
works at the DuPont Library
and Dupont was quite responsible
for the Manhattan Project.
So this memo between Eugene
Wigner and Leo Szilard--
one of whom won the Nobel
Prize, the other one
probably should have--
said, hey, radiation
stores energy
by neutron collisions like
cold working and amorphization.
So we've dug up this original
memo from the 40s, and said,
let's do this for everything
because every defect has
its unique amount of
energy that it stores
and creating it in
some different amount
of eV per defect, and we've
done some molecular dynamics
simulations to show that
this amount of energy stored
is pretty universal.
When you irradiate something, we
predict that it stores about 2%
of its energy in
radiation defense.
So if you know the number
of neutrons that hit,
and you know that the amount
of energy per neutron,
you know how much
you're looking for.
You know what your
signal should be.
And to jump through to the whole
idea of differential scanning
calorimetry, it's
like what I drew here,
but a lot more legible.
You simply heat two
materials, one of which
contains your sample,
measure their temperature,
and look how much energy it
takes between them to keep them
at the same temperature.
We did some of
these measurements
on a piece of steel from
the nuclear reactor,
and we got a whole
bunch of interesting
looking peaks for the
red curve compared
to the blue curve in the
other irradiated conditions,
so we think there's
something there.
So we tried a more controlled
experiment irradiating
aluminum with helium
ions and the accelerator
in Northwest 13.
And we were encouraged
because the initial time
that we heated this material,
we got some stored energy
out of it in some funky
spectrum that might tell us
what the defects are.
The bad news is we got that
with the control heat too,
and the really bad news
is that when you normalize
all these curves,
you get something
that you can't tell if I
drew it or my son drew it.
Looks suspiciously
like the doodles
that he does, not
scientific data.
And the problem is that
DSC, differential scanning
calorimetry, induces a lot
of artifacts in the signal
that we couldn't
separate from the noise.
So our solution was to go nano.
To use a nano a DSC, or
nano differential scanning
calorimeter, that can
heat about 10,000 times
faster than a traditional DSC.
So you can get your energy
out from smaller materials
way faster than these artifacts
can manifest themselves.
What we think is
going to happen is
that every one of
these peaks here
is going to correspond to one
type of defect that's released
at a certain temperature.
And by extrapolating, or
say, integrating the area
under those curves, you get the
energy in each type of defect.
And by extrapolating
to a zero heating rate,
you should know which
type of defect they are.
And if you know which
defects you have
and how many of each one,
you know the full defect
properties and
material, you should
know it's material properties.
Because we already know if you
have this many dislocations,
it's this brittle, the question
is how many dislocations.
So we start off by--
we use a different
kind of calorimeter.
It actually fits on a chip.
In fact, there's two on a chip.
There's one that we
put our material on,
and one as a reference
that we both put
in the accelerator being
irradiated at the same time
to control for that
effect, and this is
what they actually look like.
The scale bar here
is 100 microns,
and that transparent spot
is a little bit of aluminum
that we vapor deposited
onto the calorimeter.
Right there.
And so the way this process
works, is we take our DSC chip,
we put a mask over it,
vaporize some aluminum
to deposit on one
of the calorimeters,
take the mask away, and
irradiate the whole thing,
and then finally put it
in the nanocalorimeter,
and I'll show you what
happens slowed down
by a factor of 1,000.
That pulse right there.
That whole thing just went from
zero to 450c a millisecond.
And the reason it took
a second is because I've
slowed down the video by
4,000 or by 5,000 times,
and that little pulse
of heat actually
released some of
the defect energy.
We were able to see very
clearly, the first time we
heated the sample,
this extra area
corresponds to some
sort of energy release.
We then heated that same
sample a whole bunch of times,
and made sure that it was
always the same, which meant we
had a fully relaxed material.
And it shows some
sort of a trend.
If you note this data was
taken like two months ago,
it's pretty fresh.
Not published yet, so
hopefully by the time
this video comes
out, it will be.
And we see some sort of
trend between the amount
of irradiation it gives and
the amount of stored energy
you can get out of it.
So this is what we hope can be
used instead of those Charpy
coupons.
We can go much, much
smaller and just take out
tiny pieces of the vessel
and get the same information
as you would from a Charpy
test but on the nanoscale.
So the question then is, where
is the defect fingerprints?
Where are those
individual defects
that we were looking for?
Well, I think they're just
popping up right here.
The reason for that is we
picked a very fast heating rate
for our experiments, and doing
these sorts of measurements
on other materials shows that
at 10,000 Kelvin per second--
think about that for a second--
10,000 Kelvin per second.
So in a millisecond,
something heats up
by 10 K, which is ridiculous.
Yeah, something like that.
You don't really see any peaks.
The heating is so fast
that the defects don't even
have time to find each other,
annihilate, and release
their stored energy.
So we need to repeat the
experiments at some lower
temperatures, see
what the peaks are,
but if you go too low, you
end up getting a lot of noise
in your signal.
So there's going to be some
sweet spot that we haven't yet
found in order to see
this stored energy.
So we're just at the very
first experimental stage
of trying to see can we
extend reactor lifetimes.
After doing
simulations for a year
that probably no one
believes until you
do an experiment, including me.
But for now, it actually
shows some sort of a trend,
so it's just enough
justification for us
to buy one of these
nanocalorimeters
and start looking for real.
So if you want to see, now I've
taken you from basic material
science, to where's
the field going to,
how do we keep our reactors
running in about two hours.
I think that's the most
compact introduction
to nuclear materials I
can possibly give you.
So any questions on
what you've seen today?
AUDIENCE: Is that roughly
the trend you would expect?
MICHAEL SHORT: Yes,
I would expect an up.
That's the best I can say.
As far as is it actually a line?
Is it a curve?
I am not as brave or stupid as
some of the other folks that
will draw an arbitrary shaped
line through a single data
point.
So I'm not drawing
a trend line yet.
Yeah, any other questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is it-- or I guess
you're making the assumption
that one little spot in the
reactive pressure vessel
to say what the rest of the
vessel has been exposed to?
MICHAEL SHORT: Oh, not at all.
Take a whole bunch.
Then, instead of just
doing Charpy coupons
of one place, which is what
we do now, you can get a map.
We don't have that
information now,
but if you take pieces
from all over the vessel,
then you get an actual 3D
map instead of a single point
of saying all right,
well, we picked
what we think is going to
be the worst condition.
How do you know?
You don't.
How do you know for sure?
You make measurements
like these.
Any other questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What would
a peak in this graph
correspond to in terms of like--
How does it relate to some
sort of damage effect?
MICHAEL SHORT: We would
expect that a peak would
relate to a certain type of
defect reaction occurring.
When some type of defect gets
high enough in temperature
that it goes from stuck to
mobile, and as that moves,
it encounters anything else
it will in the material,
and will react with all
the other defects nearby,
decimating the
population of that defect
and slightly depressing
that of the others.
And as you go higher, and
higher in temperature,
the slower and slower
defects start to move.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So you can
get rid of the defects
by heating it quickly?
MICHAEL SHORT: Mm-hmm
AUDIENCE: Would there be a way
to self repair our radiation
damage to pressure
vessels themselves?
MICHAEL SHORT: That
would be awesome.
But the properties of the
vessel are highly dependent on,
not just its composition,
but the heat treatment
that went to make it.
If you heat that
vessel, you both
remove the radiation damage and
remove the strengthening put
in by the forging
and heating process.
So you would have,
if-- again, if you
let's say, replace the vessel
you have a new reactor.
If you heat the
vessel too much, it's
no longer a code stamp vessel.
Pretty tricky spot
that we're in, huh?
But we're trying to
science our way out of it.
Well, it's a couple
minutes after.
I don't want to keep you longer,
but I'll open on Thursday
with a little story about
how mass attenuation
coefficients can get you out
of apartheid South Africa.
I'm serious.
And then we'll move into
dose and biological effects.